foreign
[Music]
manager with Google Cloud
and today I'm going to share how you can
secure your development environments and
overall software supply chain with the
Google Cloud software delivery Shield
products along with two recently
introduced products in general
availability caloric stations and
assured open source software
let's start with an overview of software
delivery Shield before we do our deep
Dives in Clorox stations in a shared
open source software but first what is a
software supply chain
most software products are made up of
the source code the organization
directly rights and third-party software
in the form of dependencies
a build process then combines these
sources and outputs package software
which in turn can be run directly by
organization or consumed by other
parties
the dependencies used can be either open
source or commercial products but in
either case that software will have
contributors a software development life
cycle process of its own and its own
third-party dependencies as you can see
this constitutes a software supply chain
where you can be a consumer A supplier
or both
so now there are various attack vectors
for software Supply chains ways in which
someone can intentionally or
accidentally compromise your software
here you can see the wide range of
categories of attack vectors from Source
threats like writing insecure code or
any dependencies with
non-vulnerabilities such as for example
another version of the log4j library to
build tracks all the way to deployment
and run time threats such as a
compromise continuous deployment process
introducing unwanted changes
there are many attack vectors a holistic
solution is required it only takes one
unsecured link to bridge the software
supply chain
software delivery Shield was built from
the ground up with the need of a
comprehensive software supply chain
Security in mind as you can see here it
covers the key Source threats
for development it enables shifting
security left with secure cloud-based
IDs powered by Clorox stations data
exfiltration prevention mechanisms via
Beyond Corp Enterprise and dependency
vulnerability detection as code is being
written
for software Supply it provides a
portfolio of assured open source
software packages and vulnerability
scanning including transitive
dependencies
for CI and CD it enables organization to
have build provenance and to generate
software bill of materials
and finally for runtime it supports
analysis for misconfigurations and
continuous scanning of vulnerabilities
for running services
let's now talk about Supply security
assured open source software is now
available in GA allowing your
organization to improve their software
supply chain security by incorporating
the same trusted open source packages
that Google uses internally to your
workflows
this means increased confidence in your
software security with enriched metadata
around non-vulnerabilities continuous
vulnerability scanning as well as a
dedicated patching team that works hand
in hand with the community for mediating
issues
let's now shift to development
environment security
we've recently announced the general
availability of cloud workstations a new
product built support the day-to-day
development needs of large and small
development teams
it provides customizable development
environments available in seconds
anywhere and from a browser
all of this is done in a reproducible
way
addressing the typical works on my
machine kind of problems your developers
may have it allows you to run code
against your real Services prevent the
issues associated with emulation
finally it has a series of butane
security mechanisms to help you
strengthen your security posture
you can see some of the new capabilities
available will be covering today
but before I start our Deep dive
let me talk about the main challenges
we've heard from our customers that
guided the design of cloud workstations
first getting a developer starting on a
project takes too long or in a new team
especially getting a development
environment setup
and this became even more complex with
the recent increase in remote work
next multiple developer in-loop friction
points such as accessing private
resources is low builds or slow
downloads or uploads are simplified once
you move your development environment to
the cloud
and finally it is challenging to secure
local devices and the data is starting
it the moment you have data you start on
local machines you are bound to increase
your attack surface
let me now show you how caloric stations
addresses these challenges
first
development environment setup this video
shows an example of how you can get an
environment up and running in a few
minutes
you are here creating a development
environment following a workstation
configuration once you create one
configuration
it can be reused as a template for other
Clorox stations in shared among
developers and development teams in
Sharing consistency
each developer gets their own VM which
starts fast because they keep a poo of
warm VMS pre-configured and ready to go
on standby
this however is much more than just a
code editor in a VM developers and
platform teams can also pre-load a code
repo libraries dependencies and ID
extensions in this case we have a
development environment for Java with
code samples jdk and ID extension
pre-configured
next
to allow developers to accelerate
machine learning and data processing
tasks
Clorox stations now supports GPU
acceleration in public preview including
a wide range of platforms such as Nvidia
a100 and T4 gpus
this allow developers and data
scientists to benefit from GPU
acceleration on their preferred data
science platform be it Jupiter lab
Visual Studio code or pycharm
next extended region support we're
excited to hear the interest of
developers across the globe on cloud
workstations and to address our those
requests we've now extended our support
to 17 locations across three continents
including new locations such as India
Japan France Switzerland and North
Virginia
this will allow you to host your Clorox
stations closer to your staging and
production resources
let's now switch to developer
productivity
multiple professional R users and data
science teams prefer posit workbench as
their data analysis and integrated
development experience providing an
integrated end-to-end developer solution
that maximizes the productivity
and to better serve this community we've
partnered with posit who now provides
managed posit workbench with rstudio Pro
IDs in cloudwork stations in public
preview with support for customers to
bring their own existing licenses
posit workbench is available immediately
as part of the Clorox station's ga
we then well composite workbench and
rstudio to our family of supported
managed IDs
as a reminder to all developers to
benefit from remote development without
changing workflow with bigger correct
stations to have multi-ig support and we
currently have around 10 supported IDs
such as IntelliJ pycharm Ruby mine Rider
or vs code with more IDs such as
jetbrains Fleet in the works
next Beyond browser-based IES Clorox
stations also supports other common
development interfaces
first as you can see here you can use
your own local jetbrains Ides via
jetbrains gateways
but if you prefer to use local Visual
Studio code you can access your
workstations for remote development via
SSH
for more advanced use cases you can also
set up SSH and even TCP tunnels from
cheering stations from your local
machine finally I want to talk about the
security and data extrateration
prevention capabilities of Clorox
stations which ensure organizations can
provide the security guard rails they
need
to enable a zero trust security posture
on your development environments we've
now integrated Beyond Corp Enterprise
with cloudwork stations
enabling data protection capabilities
that detect
and prevent codex filtration on
downloads save copy and paste events
as you can see in this short demo this
provides one additional layer of defense
against exfiltration threats
in addition we've also introduced
support for context our access policies
allowing you to create access policies
based on attributes such as device
security status location IEP address and
many more
in addition to the endpoint security
enabled by the on-corp Enterprise all
workstation resources can be created
inside of your shared VPC Network and it
can access your private environments
with vpcs service controls integration
this means you can enforce the same
policies used for your Production
Services to workstations and development
environments such as automatic disk
backups or limit access sensitive
resources or user action logging
all access to caloric stations is
controlled by IEM and you can also
enforce a fully private Ingress and
egress Gateway so only users inside of
your private Network can access your
workstations if needed
Clorox stations also makes it easy to
centrally manage environment
configurations
in addition to the Google Cloud console
and the workstation API interfaces
platform teams can now also use the
Google Cloud CLI and terraform providers
to manage the workstations similarly to
how they manage their broader
infrastructure as code
you can also seamlessly update those
environments so that if you patch your
workstation configuration today by
tomorrow morning all the workstation of
your developers will be updated
one last thing devops Turing support
you may have a variety of tried and
tests tools you use and prefer
this could include tools such as
Google Cloud build but also third-party
tools such as gitlab or team City
correct stations also supports accessing
tools that can be self-hosted on-prem or
in other clouds so that you have to
modify none of your devops or production
workflows to incorporate that to your
setup
and that's it for today so to recap
today you saw that Clark stations allows
your organization to increase developer
security and productivity
that assured open source software allows
you to increase the security of your
dependencies and that software delivery
Shield provides a comprehensive holistic
solution for securing your software
supply chain
you can then learn more about them by
visiting
cloud.google.com workstations
or
cloud.google.com assure assured Dash
open dash Source software and thank you
[Music]